good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday a lot going
on
but some big trends too and you think
about them you often wonder what is
going on
and for quite some time now we've
wondered what's going on with
congressional republicans a lot of nice
people in the republican party
but the point of a political party is
not to be nice it's to represent the
interests of its voters that's the only
reason political parties exist in the
first place there's no other reason to
have them
except to represent their own voters yet
year after year on
issue after issue the leadership of the
republican party
fails to represent its voters and we're
not guessing about that
we know what republican voters care
about they tell pollsters all the time
and since they kept getting ignored in
2016 they elected donald trump just to
make it incredibly clear what they cared
about
that wasn't a wake-up call nothing would
be and nothing really changed
it remains true as of right now that the
priorities of the people who run the
republican party are very different in
some cases completely different
from the priorities of the people who
vote republican
why is that well there are a lot of
reasons for it probably but frank luntz
is definitely one of those reasons
once dr frank i lunz as he is often
called at his request
is the republican party's longest
serving message man
for decades frank luntz has told elected
republicans
what to say and precisely how to say it
luntz massages language for politicians
he does it now just this week in fact
the national
republican congressional committee the
nrcc
invited once to florida for its
so-called policy summit
where he was asked to weigh in on the
hot topics once his job was to tell
republicans office holders people with
power how to think about the most
important issues of the day
now we didn't hear the presentation but
there's no doubt it was compelling
frank luntz is a smooth salesman that's
why he's been around for a while
the problem with frank lunz is that his
views his personal views
are very different from those of your
average republican voter
frank luntz is a conventional liberal
his main clients are left-wing
corporations like google
when frank luntz gives advice to
congressional republicans
he's got google's perspective in mind
that's a huge
problem we wanted to talk to once about
all of this on the show tonight nothing
personal but it's interesting and it's
important
so we texted him in the invitation this
morning but he did not respond
that's odd since we've known him well
for a long time in 2019 for example he
tweeted us this greeting which tells you
a lot about the kind of person frank
luntz is quote
this thanksgiving let's give thanks to
the men and women of the fbi the cia
and the intel services that's literally
what the message said it's on the screen
even on thanksgiving frank luntz takes
time to bow before the powerful
so why does frank luntz remain a fixture
in republican politics
at a time when the companies he works
for are opposed to the republican party
explicitly so well in part because he is
particularly close to the house minority
leader kevin mccarthy of california and
has been since mccarthy entered politics
in an interview earlier this year lunch
described kevin mccarthy as a personal
friend
and that relationship gives frank lund's
outsized influence over the republican
party's policy positions
the big ones take the border crisis
frank luntz's view of immigration is
very much like google's view of
immigration
america needs a lot more immigration
right away
and anyone who disagrees with that is
racist
now rather than simply say that out loud
rather than make the case for his own
opinions
franklin slyly dresses up his own
personal opinions
as social science he'll conduct
something called a focus group
that's a moderated conversation between
several people that has in fact
no actual relevance to anything it's
just random people yammering
your 90-second exchange with the ups guy
this morning
meant more than a frank lund's focus
group and yet purely on the basis of
that
irrelevant conversation luntz manages to
make pronouncements about the country
and how the republican party should
respond to it
most of those pronouncements as you can
imagine tend to comport perfectly with
his own views
as well as with the views of google
executives axios recently reported on
luns's findings about immigration so
what did frank lunt supposedly find out
about immigration
well it turns out according to frank
luntz that republican voters
in fact are dying to give amnesty
to as many foreign nationals as they
possibly can they're demanding it right
away
it's a top priority for them watch
they believe in immigrants in
immigration they are pro-immigration
and i honestly i was a little surprised
because of what i see
report in the media trump voters support
the dream act they support the ability
of these people who are brought here
to no fault of their own the ability to
earn a path to
citizenship we need these people we
actually
have an economy that's expanding that's
growing
i was a little surprised to find out
that deep down republican voters agree
with me
and google we were not surprised we're
all the children of immigrants he told
us we need these people
now that may be entirely true or maybe
it's not true we can debate it
but lutz doesn't want to debate it
probably didn't come on tonight
he wants instead to pretend that his
personal opinions are established fact
and that the republican party had better
listened to them and obey
open borders activists immediately
seized upon once's
research to justify what they were
already doing keeping the borders open
the national immigration forum tweeted
out a link right away
daca has bipartisan support the group
wrote
pointing to frank luntz's opinions
posing his research
as evidence of that passing the dream
act is an
opportunity to make real meaningful
progress
you see amnesty has broad bipartisan
support
there's a national consensus in favor of
opening the border so republicans had
better get on board because frank
luntz's research proves
they desperately want it
this is pretty close to fraud actually
who is served by
it that's always the question in
washington well frank lunz's corporate
clients are served by it of course but
also the democratic party
is served by it a party whose priorities
frank luntz appears to support
here he is back in 2012 telling the rest
of us that according to his
highly scientific surveys of a dozen
people in some shopping mall somewhere
most americans actually really want the
government to take their guns away
the public wants guns out of the schools
not in the schools and they're not
asking for a security official
or someone else i don't think the nra is
listening
i don't think that they understand most
americans would protect the second
amendment rights
and yet agree with the idea that not
every human being should own a gun not
every gun should be available at any
time
anywhere for anyone yeah
most people agree notice the language
there did you listen carefully that
you can protect the second amendment
even as you gut it
it's just common sense gun control most
americans are for that
who does that sound like it sounds a lot
like joe biden
a man frank luntz has been friends with
for a long time
check out the note from frank luntz to
hunter biden on hunter's laptop
what you just heard in that clip were
democratic party talking points
but if you'd like more there's this this
is an interview from last summer
in which frank luntz explains that the
phrase law and order
is somehow offensive to most americans
keep in mind that at the very moment
frank luntz was saying this american
cities were on fire
people were dying why because there was
no law
and no order well i was critical that he
used the words law and order
he is assuming that we have the same
politics as 1968.
donald trump doesn't realize that you
can govern
in a strong stable successful way
and still use language that is warm
and kind and empathetic
stopping riots isn't warm and kind and
empathetic
doesn't help equity if that sounds a lot
like something a corporate hr executive
might say you should not be surprised by
that as we told you a minute ago
luntz's main business is not helping the
republican party you know his main
business is working for left-wing
companies that despise the republican
party
are horrified by republican voters and
everything they believe
frank lentz's long list of corporate
clients include jeff bezos's amazon
facebook nike coca-cola disney delta
airlines
the chamber of commerce these are the
people who pay frank luntz's bills
in his spare time frank lunds tells
kevin mccarthy how to run the republican
party now you can do one you can't do
both
you can see the conflict here and you
wonder
how has this been allowed to continue in
case you think we are overstating frank
luntz's allegiance to corporate power
take a look at his twitter feed sometime
if you're ever bored quote
delta employees made them the top-rated
airline he wrote last january
in what sounded very much like a press
release that's something only good
workers can do
not shareholders then not long ago when
donald trump called for boycotting
coca-cola and delta airlines after they
interfered in a very shocking way right
in the middle of georgia's political
system
once came to the defense of them of
course they're his clients
this left-wing canceled culture was out
of control he wrote mockingly
you gotta wonder if coca-cola and delta
airlines sent him a bonus for that
we don't know they should have either
way
toting for big corporations clearly pays
well
here's frank lund showing off the
replica of the oval office he had built
in his home
what what is where are you uh i was very
kind of donald trump to give me his
office
and uh i'm very fortunate this is real
this is this is
a chair this is not a photograph this is
actually my home
in uh california this is a 78
replica of the oval office and over here
as i turn this around this is the
lincoln bedroom
so i'm the only person who has an oval
office that you can actually
sleep in and you don't have to be a
presidential intern
and this is a genuine resolute desk i'm
going to put it there behind me
so you can see including the buck stops
here
wow uh we've got the humidor from bill
clinton let's see if i can get that in
the shot
there you go these are couches from bill
clinton
this is the whole thing
so obviously you could be pretty meat
about mean about that i mean it's
pretty weird but the point of this is
not to attack frank luntz personally
nice enough guy the question is ask
what's really going on here
would you take medical advice for
example from frank luntz should you have
to
well if you've listened to him recently
he very much wants you to take the
vaccine vaccines are great
only a crazy person wouldn't get the
shot frank luntz hasn't said a lot
however about his longtime work for
pfizer
huh that's weird nor does he brag about
his work for purdue pharma
remember that company purdue pharma
those are the people that got rural
america addicted to opioids kind of
wrecked the center of the country
in 2003 as the opioid epidemic
devastated the
entire regions of the united states
franklin's encouraged people
to take more oxycontin are we making
this up no we're not
quote i'm a proponent of the
pharmaceutical industry frank luntz told
pbs
i'm a supporter of a very famous
medication right now oxycontin
because i think that this is a miracle
drug which allows people to get through
the day
now some people frank launched
acknowledged quote want to see oxycontin
take
taken off the market but not frank luntz
he was taking money from purdue pharma
quote i believe that there are things
worth fighting for
yeah apparently a lawsuit filed against
purdue pharma by the state of
massachusetts in 2019
includes multiple references to frank
luntz according to that suit
luntz and his company helped purdue
pharma devise ways of quote
deflecting blame from purdue's addictive
drugs by
stigmatizing people who become addictive
the state of vermont filed a similar
lawsuit against purdue pharma
and it also mentioned frank luntz
according to those lawsuits
lunds proposed that purdue pharma adopt
a strategy of emphasizing some quote
key messages that work by those words
were spelled in
all caps for emphasis one of those
messages and we're quoting
it's not addiction it's abuse it's about
personal responsibility right
so your 19 year old just died of a drug
od
after purdue pharma flooded your town
with addictive narcotics but stop
complaining
it's her fault she died it's about
personal responsibility
this is the guy republican leaders just
went to
this week for quote messaging guidance
on hot topics
and you wonder why you no longer
recognize the party that you vote for
pedro gonzalez is a senior